hallo mein name ist klug und meine
lieben freunde es wurde sich so
unverhohlen ich von euch gewünscht von
der darf ich heute nach wochen endlich
mal wieder begrüßen zu einer neuen
episode
hier ist auch bei den bisherigen mobile
mann der es mit luca videos der fall
weiß auch das heutige video wieder
freundlich unterstützt worden von google
play im rahmen der playon kampagne und
wir spielen heute das spiel die elder
scrolls blakes die ersten paar minuten
habe ich hier schon gespielt allerdings
habe ich gedacht die staaten jetzt mal
die aufnahme weil wir uns jetzt einen
charakter erstellen können das jetzt
eine rot-rote sprachenlernen hatte ich
gehe mal einen nach links
da sehen wir haben ein
[Musik]
die person sieht mir glauben schon
relativ ähnlich allerdings bin ich nicht
weiblich sondern männlich antwort ja
doch das bin ja eins zu eins ich quasi
und so boni sind rüstungs wert plus 5
prozent und schaden mit fähigkeiten plus
fünf prozent aber leider - 100% weil der
charakter von mir gesteuert wird
allerdings liegt mir jetzt einfach mal
direkt auf weit haben jetzt können wir
unsere körpergröße aus wir sind extrem
groß aber extrem breit natürlich so wie
ich auch in echt was ist das hier auch
das ist unsere farbe ich würde sagen
dass das passte so schon ganz gut haare
haben wir natürlich keine augen und nase
würde ich sagen war ja mal so hier so
ein bisschen wie er weiß ja auch egal
sonstiges dies
als kläger wenigstens hat einer von uns
beiden jetzt im bad gesichtsbemalung
kann ich mir auch noch aussuchen
ich würde sagen ich lass das jetzt mal
york player 3000 heißen wir und jetzt
immer und jetzt sind wir fertig mit der
erstellung unseres charakters natürlich
ihr seid ist ja das ist dieser junius
das habt ihr nicht mitbekommen aber
bevor ich gerade das video gestartet
habe habe ich schon ein paar minuten
gespielt und ein wir müssen das jetzt
auf jeden fall der junior tsunami
getroffen und mussten jetzt gerade
unseren charakter erstellen seid gegrüßt
org player 3000 jahre als ich meine so
hieß ja jeder im mittelalter junius hat
mich schon für tot gehalten das lag
allerdings daran dass ich auf der suche
nach abenteuern war ich wünschte ich
hätte das getan als die gelegenheit dazu
hatte blabla ja wir antworten jetzt
einfach mal ein bisschen ich will weiter
kämpfen
das war so neu ist jetzt für ihn
gespielt aber ich habe alle getötet
deren bruder julius gibt uns jetzt auf
jeden fall noch ein paar heiltränke
wünschen uns viel glück m und wir haben
jetzt eine quest ist endlich öffnete
anschließend das kreuz mit ok rettet die
stadtbewohner
können sie sich nicht selbst also
kriegen wir mal auf starrte mich muss
die stadtbewohner auf jeden fall
befreien die von den goblins in der
verlassenen burg hochwinter gefangen
gehalten werden
es stimmt mal oben ab ob ihr ob ihr
denkt dass ich das schaffe die 100
prozent nachdem also wir sind in der
burg angekommen
das blaue wasser hinterher schrieb das
ist der hält sich vor was bist du denn
was ist das
ich muss kämpfen was ist das da führt
hier
das war eine ratte der faden zeigt man
auf jeden fall an wo ich lang laufen
soll einem amateur auf oder nochmal
bitte kann mir die tür auf
a
ja hallo ist hier irgendwo ist hier
irgendwelche spieler was ist das was was
ist das werk in slate noch nicht lange
von links in den muss gedrückt halten
und nicht im passenden moment loslassen
dann ist der tod
genau ja das hast du davon ich habe
nämlich drei schwarzen gut drin war 1938
schon ufc und mr
ja mein kalkstein erhalten alter ist
keine toilette mit saubermachen
[Gelächter]
also schauen wir mal hier vornherein ein
stadtbewohner habe dann ja gar kein
problem bruder der anführer der goebbels
hat immer noch landrat man long tail der
also lohnt der stadt schmid ist noch
gefangen habe wohl ein witz bin ich
irgendwie helfen den zu kriegen was
glänzte nach oben so dass eine ahnung
was das hier ist soll ich das irgendwie
+14 gesundheit hier stelle ich mir vor
dass wir im echten leben wieso man läuft
einfach so rum man hat sich den arm
gebrochen
haha da ja kurz darauf mein name ist
heide allerdings ist es leider nicht so
im echten leben ja wir schauen hier
allerdings mal weiter hier vorne ist
auch noch was was ist das hier das ist
was das geld ja 40 euro ja
wahrscheinlich euro frühe mittelalter
und nahmen wir auch noch was das ist das
ist einfach ich stehe im feuer
allerdings sagen wir bewegen uns mal
hier vorne hin zu tür wieder aufgemacht
die session wieder kommen dass gleich
eine ratte auf mich zu sprintet von
irgendwo im laufen wir hier um darum
warum lirum larum löffelstiel immer
gesagt keine ahnung was das hier unten
ist es ist eine das ist eine karotte da
liegt einfach eine karotte
wer kennt ihn nicht den ort player 3000
wenn er keine gesundheit hat dann frisst
er einfach irgendwelche vergammelten
karotten die in der burg von hochwinter
liegen ihren paar sekunden später wurde
ich wusste das sind laut konnten klaus
vor allem nicht norden koppel in mein
gott es stimmt einfach spielklasse
erschreckt mich ja die ganze zeit ich
bin ein sehr sehr schreckhafte mensch
was ist das hier belohnungen ich habe
180 euro bruder es sind immer noch keine
euros oder pelz rüstung bekommen und
drei kalksteine alter keine toiletten
werden sich freuen das haben wir jetzt
hier werben cacau europas ist das ist
ein helleres audi kann ich mir die kann
ich mir anziehen
hier vorne haben wir auch etwas rum
liegen
da hatten wir vorhin ein bisschen geld
drin jetzt haben wir hier ein gruppe ist
das da jackson ich würde das sind
einfach irgendwelche leute die hier ja
die stadtbewohner festhalten aber ich
weiß auch nicht wo sind sie denn die
stadtbewohner hier vorne haben noch was
drin
das sind wieder einfach nur kerzen aber
hier haben wir noch was und zwar kann
ich dir einfach mal drauf schlagen dann
haben wir was wir da drin gehabt ein
marmor steht oben rechts ok es
interessant laufen wir mal weiter durch
ich wiederkommen da haben wir auch schon
wieder was drin
das ist der wahnsinn was haben wir hier
wurde ich bin gespannt einer honigwabe
ich hasse roni boniek ist einfach zucker
baumann bruder ihr müsst die ganze hier
ankommen denkt
das ist irgendwie war es wird also klar
ich meine ich töte heute also das ist
hier vorne liegt holz hier hinter ist
das noch eine kiste die will ich gerne
haben tor ist verschlossen finde den
hebeln 1
wir setzen uns prioritäten und finden
die stadtbewohner muss man ja ganz klar
so sagen er auch bruder goldman banker
ihr habt ihr nichts besseres zu tun als
sich mit mir auf zeit mich meinem bett
bisher alle gestorben und guck dich an
du bist jetzt auch tot
na gut laufen wir weiter wir haben wir
da hinten das ist nicht wie ein gockel
informieren kümmern habe ich allerdings
eine eine fähigkeit punkt den ich mir
hier draufpacken kann und zwar gern ich
mir den mächtigen angriff dort haben wir
jetzt hier gemacht dann gehe ich mal
wieder zurück jetzt schauen wir mal den
doppeln davon an der iss ein
ausrufezeichen darüber um ist ein
ausrufezeichen gruppe ist das ein master
der auszog gesichtsbemalung aber gut ich
hab es ja alle besiegt von daher kommt
ihr bruder opel in der wak ok kraft der
schein dann anscheinend ein bisschen
krasser zu sein allerdings ich habe
meinen letzten schlag ausgerüstet wird
eigentlich keine chance haben
ich will einfach der geborene kämpfer
den haben wir hier vorne retten
stadtbewohner ich dachte schon ich werde
hier sterben ist das lohnt bruder miguel
portillo habt es geschafft ich wusste
dass auf euch verlassen es ist wunderbar
dass die leute zurückkommen aber nun
müssen wir uns um die stadt selbst
kümmern
ja stimmt junius ich muss allerdings
erst mal kurz wissen
wir sollten hier mit der stadthalle
anfangen sie kann als unterkunft dienen
bis wir mehr häuser wieder aufgebaut
haben und als audio das habe ich auch
gelesen man kann eigene städte
erschaffen also unsere neue quest ist
der wiederaufbau der stadt halle habe
ich mich besonders darauf gefreut bei
dem spiel weil man halt nicht so die
stadthalle wieder aufbauen kann sondern
du kannst die komplett eigene städte
bauen
es gibt auch noch in extrem krassen pvp
modus wo man online gegen andere spieler
in arenen antreten kann also das spiel
ist extrem umfangreich staaten namen
eingeben wähler einen namen zwischen 3
und 16 buchstaben köln bruder unsere
stadt alles fertiggestellt freundin
guckt ihr euch mal das ist hätten
deshalb ein spiel was ich gerade auf
meinem google pixel hier spielen guckt
euch mal die grafik an bruder was ist
los ja okay ich gehe mal zu junius hin
was er sagt danke dass ihr uns geholfen
habt unsere standorte aufzubauen
hoffentlich gibt das läuten mute wieder
zurückzukommen und was jetzt muss noch
etwas gebaut werden sage ich meine ich
habe gehört dass ihr den schmied der
stadt gerettet habt sehr gut er wird uns
bald helfen können waffen und rüstungen
ich würde gern mal so ein pvp kampf
machen allerdings kann man die arena
leider erst ab stufe 5 betreten meine
lieben freunde von daher wenn ihr wollt
dass ich das spiel eventuell nochmal
spiele bei einem ob ein mann der hier
auf meinem kanal dann lasst auf jeden
fall einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da an der stelle wird das heutige
video auch beende meine stadt sieht
ziemlich chaotisch aus also ich glaube
ich muss wirklich irgendwann nochmal
zweiten teil machen weil das sieht ja
schlimmer aus als in meinem kinderzimmer
wenn euch das erste video des comebacks
von bombay man jetzt mit luca allerdings
gefallen hat dann schreibt es mir gerne
in die kommentare meine lieben freunde
an der stelle auch noch mal ein großes
dankeschön an google play das im rahmen
der player kampagne das heutige video
wieder freundlicher weise unterstützt
haben abonnieren gern meinen kanal falls
auch kein luxus sein und jetzt befinden
wir uns auch im auto
und ja ihr kennt so habe ich noch aus
den ganzen anderen episoden hier findet
ihr ein altes video verlinkt findet ihr
das spiel verlinkt ladet euch gern mal
runter ist es extrem geil das ist extrem
umfangreich und ich bin jetzt mal weg